- I'm excited to drink
some hot, chunky goo.
- A little nauseous, 'cause
they all kinda look like
an animal had diarrhea.
- This smells like Almond Joy.
- I think this is coconut.
- All right, it's coconut-y.
- Mounds.
- I kind of like Mounds better as a drink.
- Number two.
- This looks awful.
- Gettin' a lotta crunch.
- Either that, or like boiled beetles.
- Exceptionally chunky.
- Mmm, (scared laughing) I'm
not excited about this one.
- Sorry, I have a spoonful
of mostly soggy peanuts.
- I'm just gonna go with, say, Snickers?
- Snickers has that many
whole peanuts in it?
- This one looks cute.
- There's almost no smell,
which is really alarming.
- It's a little more gunky.
- What is in here?
Oh my God.
(tasting sounds)
- There's something frothy about it.
- It's almost like a gross poop latté.
- It's like a marshmallow, I think.
- When you clean out
your garbage disposal.
- That one leaves a really
strong mouth coating.
- I'm gonna say Three Musketeers.
- Three Musketeers is just
(bleep) (bleep) Milky Way.
There, I said it.
- I'm very proud of myself for this.
- Are there noodles in this?
- There's literally
pasta snakes of caramel.
- It seems like more gelatinous.
- I can't even pick it up with my spoon.
- It's the consistency of steak fat.
- I don't like anything about that.
- So I'm just trying
to think of a candy bar
that has tasteless
fettuccine strips in it.
- Ew. What are you?
I don't know what you are.
Wait a minute. I have an idea.
- The wafer
becomes a sponge in the worst way.
- I'd pay like $15 for
this at a restaurant.
- Oh, what?
- What the (bleep) are you?
- What's living in the bottom of this?
- Oh my God, there's a baby in here.
- I don't know if I wanna taste this.
- This looks like someone's organ removed.
- Exactly what a 12-year-old boy wants
after having a snowball fight.
That was perfect.
Like, that straight-up looked like
those little monster figurines
in "Ernest Scared Stupid".
I think this is first time
we ever get to reference
an Ernest film in a taste test,
but I'm thrilled about it.
- This has truly been
a terrible experience.
(laughing)
Oo.